euromaxx highlights and here's your host
Louise Houghton a warm welcome to the
highlights show today which starts off
on a lighter note and I mean that quite
literally here's what's coming up shiner
light a whole new dimension in modern
interior design done by hand matts
Gustafsson's fashion illustrations hold
their own against the camera and waste
not want not a Berlin startup is making
designer furniture from euro palette
there are a lot of people in the world
who suffer from seasonal affective
disorder which is the medical term for
feeling depressed at certain times of
the year research shows that light is
very integral to our happiness and a
berlin-based group of light designers
have been working to defy their lack of
light in the winter days they've come up
with some innovative ideas to keep
Berliners smiling as the long winter
draws in its autumn in Germany the
nights are drawing in and the Sun
becomes a rare sight
I mine enters office when you wake up
and it's darn gray outside and there's
no Sun at duck into mu 2 we shall commas
fuse on oh there's plenty of Sun where I
come from in Germany there isn't even
enough Sun for me in summer so I miss it
all year mrs. GaN Xie it was hedge boy I
walk out alone and I want to do
something for my appearance so I'll feel
better I might go to the solarium so
I'll get some Sun the designers in the
leash toyama office in Berlin know how
important light is for people the group
has already had a number of projects
they've illuminated everything from
stairwells to entire office buildings
musical mujava is a lighting designer he
specializes in making interior light as
close to daylight as possible vhd no fan
at least we wake up when it gets light
and we go to bed and when it gets dark
wait a sunlight is our reference point
and you can't improve on that you can
only simulate it very closely I couldn't
ludi money on
there are many ways to use modern
lighting elements they can be found in
swimming pools and in offices in museums
or doctors surgeries but new forms of
lighting are also being used in private
homes as well economical LED lighting
means there's more space for light than
ever before man can do farm you can
change colours several times and let
them run through automatically you can
also create an image we can use light to
set the scene to make the space always
look different and that's always
something pleasant what's onion dimas
berlin's shell heat a hospital is
carrying out research on the positive
effect light has on people a small
intensive care unit has received new
lighting
to four bedrooms have been redesigned to
offer patients more privacy and comfort
illuminated ceilings are supposed to
promote healing
I some am I might even get some text
sunrise and sundown gives us a day night
with him that makes us sleep better at
night yeah corner element there are
green elements in the room you can see
them up here that shade is conducive to
feeling protected the space has been
designed I could actually to make it
seem like a living room rather than that
storage area feeling you get another I
SI units illuminated ceilings are
supposed to relax and entertain patients
they can play with the systems elements
to change the colors look through
treetops or gaze of moving clouds
the article piety is expecting a cold
loud intensive care unit room then he
wakes up as he so friendly it is that
there's light above and it's not so loud
I think patients enjoy it a super-thin
Muslim isn't businesses are also trying
to shed new light on themselves a
shopping center in Berlin's hellas Dolph
district is being refurbished and
equipped with an LED lit ceiling licious
angin stock up light is a major driver
of feelings of well-being in both
private and public spaces given that
using lighting technologies in an
interesting and intelligent way can
influence passers-by feelings of
well-being and contribute positively to
their willingness to buy what you find
puzzle ceilings like these costs about
100 euros per square meter the price
increases in proportion to their
complexity besides looking good they
keep energy costs down to two good
reasons to lift your mood and come into
the light during the autumn and winter
seasons well while I some of clothing
that's particularly popular in the
winter months is jeans the material is
durable hard wearing and made to be worn
again and again but there comes a time
when you just want a new pair what might
be old and rugged to you though is
treasure for British artist Ian Barrie
and the more ripped faded or thin the
better it has no plans to wear them
though just to use them for his artworks
but one of his pictures will probably
cost you more than you'll ever spend on
jeans in your entire life
London as you've never seen it before
Piccadilly Circus tube station all the
view from primrose hill on the north
side of regents park at first glance Ian
Barry's works look like paintings but
look again they're made from denim the
fabric used for jeans some of those
works are currently on show at London's
catto gallery it's kind of cool um you
know it's there's the rebel bases but I
mean really it's being the kind of go to
item of clothing for maybe 50 60 years
so it's gone through so many generations
and I think everybody or I would say
like ninety ninety-five percent of the
population has a connection with jeans
around favorite pair of jeans the
exhibition includes 31 of his jeans
collages the 29 year old used urban
scenes for his subjects they're not well
known sites but they are typical of the
city there in like this collage of a new
york restaurant made of countless bits
of denim
is because of the little little tiny
bits that he just thinks about and also
finding that piece of denim to make it
work he doesn't just put any old piece
of denim in he finds a very very
specific bit i know sometimes he says he
spends as much time looking for that
piece of denim as making that piece of
denim for the picture wherever he is
barry is always on the lookout for new
material a british-born artist who
normally lives and works in Sweden he
loves spending time in camden market
while in London it's secondhand shops
are a veritable treasure trove like this
you know Timo's it looks like it's all
ripped mean yeah that's great for grass
whereas that's like you know probably
wat that's exactly why use of a subway
car I actually look more now for what
using work and what to wear in my own
personal water like about two pairs of
jeans and they often they just get
sacrificed Anita shade Barry became an
artist by accident after graduating from
graphic design school he worked in
advertising seven years ago he decided
to try his hand at art he cuts and
assembles his collages in his studio
near the Swedish city of Malmo he can
take him up to five weeks to finish a
work something which is really hard to
translate in my online video you know
print my work it you know some people
think it's all very flat of photoshopped
I mean I had friends I've seen this work
for the last seven eight years and
they've come into a gallery suddenly and
said I had no idea it was like this I
thought it was you didn't Photoshop and
his flat printed as subjects very
frequently uses hidden places that he
discovers while strolling about City one
is this typical English pub in a London
side street the pub is iconic play smart
I wouldn't say it's overdone like you
know is some some things which are all
but darkness subjects and a field at the
London pub or English pub is like real
essence of urban living but also
community especially before behind you
get locals going in and there's a place
where people all join together and
images of pubs dominate this latest show
most of the works were already sold
before the event even opened depending
on the effort that went into making them
they sold for prices between 1015
thousand euros by putting them with an
everyday fabric and everyday kind of
scene people now look at it differently
and kind of reevaluate oh yeah maybe
shops are closing down like I'll give a
shop fronts maybe like a newsstand
they're all closing down in America so
they will relook at it and think oh it's
such nice part of the fabric of the
urban environment Ian Barrie doesn't
always wear jeans besides he says most
of his trousers wear out pretty fast and
and the exhibition will run till the
11th of December there now the Italian
island of Sicily is the largest island
in the Mediterranean and it's home to
europe's largest volcano as well the
volcano is very prominent in the city of
Catania which lies at the foot of Mount
Etna and the lava was previously used as
a welcome resource for construction or
for making wine and chocolate Mount Etna
is the largest volcano in Europe right
now it's active again someone who is
well acquainted with Edna is Ranger Luca
ferlito every day for leto drives
through the ash and lava fields to help
lost tourists he'll also be the first on
the scene if Edna erupts Blundell
auto-moto when I first got the chance to
work on the volcano and feel it breathe
it nearly pulled me over hey when I cosa
gave me a place hotel minted of course I
really respect volcano young un gran de
respeto per questa Turkish Okinawa all
his life ferlito has been fascinated by
Aetna's landscape his family comes from
this region of Sicily de pico la veo tu
ne yo Padre when I was still little when
I was just too Johnny my father took me
there on an excursion that's the image
of the volcano erupting that shape of my
life la vida
during Aetna's last major eruption in
1669 streams of lava flooded into nearby
Catania today you can still see what it
was like in the basement of the city's
University t3 amo intermodal we're here
inside Catania's Benedictine monastery
only today the monastery is a university
here you see what was then the
monasteries kitchen it was built on the
lava that flowed down from aetna in 1669
a lot of the monastery and its
surrounding fields were destroyed then
the eruption nearly destroyed the city
but it left behind the materials for
rebuilding it as well today streets
houses and even the city's emblem an
elephant are made from lava stone nearby
you can even find out what Edna tastes
like in Modica people have always made
chocolate using the stone 80 year old
Luigi Bell Yeti is the last maestro of
this local tradition a single man java
first you heated the chocolate and after
it melted you stirred it and then you
poured it on to the stone these days
machines have largely replaced lava
stone the local specialty is chocolate
made with cocoa sugar vanilla and
cinnamon it's cooked at only 45 degrees
so it has an intense flavor the local
wine is also famed for its intense taste
many vineyards here are nestled on the
slopes of Etna the cambria family owns
one of them let then I see what I mean
montes now makes this region a unique
special wine-growing area it's really
what gives the whole region its
character do any hope article are
especially Dovie vinian over here the
wines have a very distinct character
they're fresh because of the altitude of
which they're grown and the mineral-rich
soil makes the volcanic wines very
strong tasting me see a warning ship
mariangela Cambria says her family has
been running the cotton era vineyard
since 1970 she's part of the second
generation the winery employs 25 people
and produces wines like
elemis Calise and Merlot good maybe no
significa teledyne is about land passion
and love it's not just a red liquid that
you pour in a glass it's also a history
of the people who believed in the
properties of the region soil and still
do da he continued nakra dirty after the
Sun sets on aetna Giovanni trim belize
day begins his wine store offers
Sicilian food with a twist this food is
prepared with local wines when the
identity began an exam or one of the
typical dishes we prepare is cauliflower
marinated in red wine yella talk I will
sort of forgotten and then and we not
also we prepare it carefully then cook
it and then serve it with another Edna
red wine because the wines fragrance and
taste is unique it can't be compared to
any other one on earth for Sicilians
aetna isn't just Europe's biggest
volcano the mountain shapes almost
everyone's life here for years fashion
designers began developing their ideas
by literally putting pen to paper it
used to be the only way they could show
the latest trends that was until
photography came into play although
there is no less fashion illustration
being done it's still very prominent in
the industry and one of the top names in
the game is mats gustafsson from sweden
with just a few deft brushstrokes mats
gustafsson creates illustrations simply
oozing grace and elegance from his 1997
work for the designer yohji yamamoto to
his current campaign for dior
his repertoire is as extensive as is
impressive the biggest element in all my
work is that I am obsessed with beauty I
own use really facial expressions it's
sort of a just a an abstraction of a
person and and and I think that has been
my way of finding a niche where I can
exist and where I can express myself and
where I can express fashion so i can
simplify i can exaggerate i can abstract
gustafson started out his career in
stockholm but he's lived in New York
since 1980 the train set designer still
has a studio in a Swedish capital and he
regularly retreats here to draw
he needs peace and quiet when embarking
on a new project and that often means
withdrawing from the hustle and bustle
of regular city life
my technique is quite simple it's
usually about works on paper and and and
I have I always start with sketches you
know pencil drawings on paper and the
medium I'm mostly working in is this
watercolor and with watercolor
especially it's also a an element of
chance you know it's not always what I
control it he first came to attention
when British Berg published pictures of
his in 1978 later the US edition of the
magazine followed suit since then
Gustafsson's drawings have appeared in
all the most important international
fashion magazines fashion illustration I
think has to somehow of course reflect
fashion and and be part of that the time
and it's aight guys if you want or and i
think i always loved fashion before I
even knew there was such a thing as
fashion gustafson sees fashion through
an artist's eyes his illustrations
feature regularly in exhibitions
worldwide the nillas gorton museum near
stockholm recently hosted a show of 90
works covering the past 30 years in
February they'll go on display in
Gothenburg illustrations or the art of
mass Costas on I think it is very
Scandinavian art he uses few colors he
uses forms and shapes and he does it in
a very minimalistic way and when he uses
so few elements they become even
stronger a hundred years ago painted
illustrations were the only medium
available for showing the latest trends
this one from 1912 is a case in point
later in the 1950s the fashion world
discovered photography watercolors and
sketches are becoming rarer but
photographs can't displace or replace
them entirely I think the reason why
illustration still is so important in
the fashion industry is because it can
focus on certain things whereas the
camera more or less just that depicts
everything and the illustrations can
enhance and make it stronger and make us
catcher just that what what the designer
wanted to show so the illustrator really
helps the designer sodimm all is stock
homes creative district Gustafson often
draws inspiration here he loves watching
people and gaining a sense of their
individual styles
I usually say that the inspiration is
not something that just around in the
air it is actually also comes to you
when you are involved in in in in the
process I think of course if the
inspiration is fashion itself fashions
change but Matt Gustafsson's
illustrations go somewhere to making
them timeless at least on paper now I'm
sure you've all seen goods being carted
around the world on TV if not in person
many of the crates used are called euro
pallets like these and they're made with
Pinewood whilst this is extremely solid
they do sometimes break their then
disposed of and that is where a
berlin-based upcycling company called
kimidori comes into play they make the
pallets into designer furniture like
this chair and their ideas are
continually evolving unwanted euro
pallets recycled and put to use by a new
berlin startup 35 year old Sebastian
Nova kofsky joined some friends and
setup kimidori in January they make
sustainable items of furniture from
recycled wood that has a history
palette annoyed at it and then ashita
this I haven't you'll it tells a story
each pallet has carried its own low lung
beeping it's been on an incredible
journey for hundreds of thousands
perhaps millions of kilometers one
either it still bears the traces of its
journey mythos you see it on each piece
wherever it comes from each planet tells
its own story wore a messy hair combed
that's it you are ironing system
kimidori buys up the pallets from
special suppliers there are an estimated
500 million of them in the world used
mainly for transporting goods they're
often discarded once they're broken or
reach a certain age alternatively the
wood is recycled clean sanded down and
turned into furniture
the chairs tables chests of drawers even
lamps are sold online in different
designs and colors each item is simply
designed but unique and cost between 200
and 600 euros and in product launch them
you can practically read where they were
made from the markings where they first
set eyes on the world as sad as it a
victim and you can still see it on our
furniture thing the faith there are
pallets from Poland Hungary Czech
Republic Austria and Germany London some
of the new furniture is made in a small
workshop in Berlin mandy's Levitsky
needs between three and eight hours to
fashion a piece of furniture depending
on how complicated that design is
I am are these module pilot they're
really nice thing about Europe pallets
is that I don't have to work down to the
millimeter in the way that I do when I'm
making a kitchen I can work in a rougher
more rustic way I've amba single-stick
higher on the dimensions are
predetermined by the slats and that
makes a nice change this is for my
Lynetta up fixham kimidori currently has
eight different designs in its range and
there are five new ones on the way at
the moment they only exist as paper
models product designer daniel becquer
has been nominated in the category of
Best Newcomer for the 2014 German design
awards at sea bass una siesta man let me
share done good fitness when Sebastian
first approached me yeah it had to me
give it to this time I had a certain
distance to the product he was the math
moment but I soon realized that pallets
Hobbit would still give me many of those
same possibilities i have with
conventional freshwater of these cat
vomit hey body components and then push
and hold so i tried not to allow myself
to be to put off by this used element
fun teasing physical capoten elemental
uplinking selassie
in order to finance the new designs the
furniture startup has launched a
crowdfunding campaign supporters can
make a financial pledge online once the
company has raised the money it needs it
plans to start production if everything
goes to plan the key me Dora team will
soon have a dozen plus designs made from
old euro pallets well that is all we
have time for today but do join us again
tomorrow when we'll kick start a brand
new week of lifestyle news from around
Europe for now though thanks for tuning
in take care of yourself and good bye
Oh
Oh